all right marissa yes marissa um so you
are you have been living on skid row yes
we've been lebanon's kid up until
recently tell me what
um well see the thing was is when we
were living on skid road we were staying
at the shelter
and so i had to go
to the hospital for like about three
days and so when i came back to the
shelter they didn't ask me for paperwork
or nothing the guards told me that i had
to leave
for two years because i wasn't in my bed
space or whatnot i explained to them
that i was at the hospital they didn't
ask me to see no papers they took all of
our stuff and they wouldn't give it back
plus a little bit of money that i had
mind you it's like eight something in
the night when i had got released almost
nine so i knew nobody right here even
though i'm from here i've been gone for
a while so so let's back up a little bit
yes
you're you've been living on skid row
with your four kids yes and two dogs yes
um
who are your kids what are your kids
names uh that's elijah erica moody and
angie
so they range in age from four seven
nine and two wow yes
tell me about how are you living in a
tent on skid row with four kids oh well
see we weren't living in our own tank we
ended up staying with my friend what she
has a fridge you know she had all the
electrical stuff she had a bed and you
know what i'm saying so by the time that
the program had found us the path
program they had entered us into a hotel
so that's where we've been staying for
the rest of the time so just recently
you got housing yeah like about four or
five months ago yeah so you've been in
the steward hotel yes um
how did you end up in this situation oh
well see i had i had my house i had my
car my job i had got hit by a truck and
dragged five miles my son got hit by the
same truck but just lesser and dragged
two miles and thrown into the main
street and so when that had happened
is when we became homeless like shortly
afterwards because i couldn't i mean i'm
in the hospital i couldn't keep up with
my bills you know
so and this is where oh that was in new
mexico yes so you're living in new
mexico and albuquerque yes
and then you
what about the father of the children
well their father lives in mexico and he
the sister of him stated that he had
passed away and this is my mind you when
i was two months pregnant so from there
on i haven't heard nothing from him
yeah you suspect that he's not passed
away well i thought that in the
beginning but like i also thought that
sister wouldn't lie to me as well you
know
so at the same time it's kind of
thinking one way and then you know what
i'm saying like him not answering or
having any kind of uh
physical contact with him is where i'm
thinking that it is true you know that
he is has passed away yes
yeah so you've been on your own for how
long now uh oh it's been a while um
i would say it's been a long while
yeah
i mean she's gonna be three soon you
know what i'm saying since the yeah
since you're you're you're you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
youngest yeah yeah
and how are you supporting yourself well
number one i was asking for ssi
i was asking for ssi and um that didn't
come through so they said that i have to
ask again for ssi and then i went
towards the government for the kids they
said that
you know these two weren't from the
you know from usa and then all of a
sudden they started making a bunch of
excuses and then from there you know
what i'm saying um
i try to get like legal assistance you
know and
like it was the time of the covet so
everything was shutting down they
weren't really helping a lot of people
so now i'm back on track and uh who's
been helping us is friends you know
church people
my uncle
my number one uncle you know so that's
what's been getting a spy you know and
besides me selling purses jury makeup
you know what i'm saying that's also
what had got us by you know are your
kids school age
yeah they they get home steady yeah so
living on the streets has got to be how
how long are you on skid row um i would
say like maybe two months
yeah not that long
yeah
wow
do you have any family anyone you can
rely on or help my uncle yeah yeah my
uncle's the one that helps us get by buy
groceries diapers wipes the necessary
needs if we need anything else besides
that you know he's the one that i go to
yeah and you're you're how old me i'm
40. you're 40. yeah
yeah but mind you i couldn't walk i was
from out of that car accident i couldn't
do nothing you know my church was coming
checking on the kids and feeding the
kids and you know even though i could
get up here and they're in the
wheelchair and whatnot you know and then
um
you know just people that i knew they
were coming by checking on the kids you
know helping out so yeah you have quite
a few scars all over your body yeah yeah
this is all from the car accident and
there's more but they're underneath so
yeah yeah yeah the right side of your
face as well yeah well this is road rash
yeah
yeah as well as this underneath my shirt
is road rash it's just a little bit more
lighter because they were able to scrub
it out
yeah
what a rough life you've you've got now
yeah but we're blessed we're still alive
we're still together we're still pushing
so we're very blessed you know what i'm
saying with the lord's help
you know miracles happen every day you
know and i'm one of the miracles
they're one of the miracles you know
what i'm saying
and drugs and drugs are not part of your
life oh no unlike everybody no way i
don't know smoke
yeah but everyone else here on skid rows
yeah well you know people do what they
want to do you know what i'm saying and
if you hang around with the crowd they
kind of you know what i'm saying say
that you're the crowd or whatnot but for
me you know they see the kids you know
what i'm saying and they know that i'm a
good mom they know that i take care of
my kids they know anybody you could ask
around here knows that i don't touch
nothing never having never will yeah
you're very protective of your oh oh
that's a hundred percent a hundred
percent especially you have to down here
uh anywhere
anywhere right it doesn't matter where
you're at you know what i'm saying you
always have to watch your babies because
that's your jewels you know what i'm
saying
you'll never get him back you know never
you know so you really got to take care
of your jewels you know what would you
like to see happen
well for me you know i'm planning on
either
trying to get you know an rv space
or
like a house you know what i'm saying if
i could ever get one i don't care what
it looks like even if we have to fix it
up you know what i'm saying but as long
as it's livable to be able to fix up
little by little you know is what i
really want to do you know what i'm
saying um
so
you know what was your childhood like oh
no god man forget it i wasn't
you you would never see my family out
anywhere you know they were very
respectable people and you know
church-going people and like if they
were alive you know they'd just be like
oh no you're not out there you know
i mean besides the other part of my
family that i don't know like that that
i went and i went to new mexico for now
those part they wouldn't really care if
we were outside or not you know
so your parents passed away oh yeah yeah
yeah
my mom i really didn't know her you know
but she's passed away and my dad he's
passed away as well so you were raised
by who oh i was raised in the government
yep and the system but my mom that i got
she was actually a good woman you know
what i'm saying i got lucky so your
biological parents why did they not yeah
yeah they passed away why do they not
raise you i don't know what happened to
them yeah i couldn't be able to tell you
did you even know them
not my not my mom my dad i did yeah my
mom i didn't know her really
yeah
did you
ever see that maybe you ever imagine
that your life could have been like this
where you're living in no
no because i had everything i had my
house my car my job i had everything you
know what i'm saying but one minute you
have
everything and then the next minute what
was the biggest factor that broke you
know that put you in this situation the
car accident
because i couldn't keep up with my bills
i was in the hospital i couldn't go to
work
and the kid's father kind of disappeared
or died yeah and and you know time was
ticking to go back to work and since i
didn't go to work you know what i'm
saying
and the bills piled up you know
so i mean i i had the people help me as
much as they could help me you know what
i'm saying but it just wasn't good
enough you know you're you're now
relying on the goodwill of of
people you meet on the streets
oh i'm not relying on them i rely on my
uncle you see what i'm saying
yeah i don't if i don't get nothing
outside my uncle always supplies for us
you know so i'm not really worried about
if somebody gives me or if they don't
give me because he always gives to us
you know that's just him he's always
been like that you know and when i have
i try to give back to him you know when
he's in need
yeah
wow yeah and pretty soon we won't be in
the hotel we'll be moving in with my
uncle
we just have to raise up a certain kind
of money that he said that he needed in
order to move from where he's living
because he's a um
he's a veteran so like they'll only help
him so far and then he has to have uh
money which he does get money every
month but it's not enough you see what
i'm saying to move into this new place
that he wants to get for all of us
yeah that way we don't have to be
back and forth or whatnot your kids are
very well behaved yeah i mean they're
squirreling around but what kids don't
you know
they're
i mean
you gotta love it
so you have elijah you have
erica
who's erica this is erica
that's angie
and moody moody
that's moody moody
and elijah pop your head up there elijah
look look in the camera
look buddy
he wants to see you in the camera can
you sit by your mom can you stand by
your mom come here baby
he's having fun on the carpet
we don't have carpet
so he's like just dragging away
[Music]
so i mean
you get depressed or angry or frustrated
over what you're going through not at
all i mean i i get pain you and i'm
saying but i just come out and walk it
off you know like i don't get mad
because there's no reason to get mad
just like when my pastor had told me he
goes marissa do you forgive this man who
did this to you and i told him i said
pastor i don't even know this man you
know what i'm saying and he goes do you
think that you could uh find it in your
heart to forgive him and i said i
forgive him you know what i'm saying but
it doesn't mean that i forget
you know what we're going through and he
goes do you think that i could invite
him to the church you know maybe he
needs a little bit of prayer and i told
him i said go ahead who am i to deny
somebody else of the lord you know what
i'm saying
so i told him i said go on ahead and
invite him if you want to you know and
he was surprised that i forgave the man
you know he was like was it a hit and
run or he didn't know that you were it
was an older man and he says that he
didn't see us but i find it kind of hard
that he don't see a big old humongous
stroller in his rear-view mirror and
underneath his tire he could hear the
pop he you could hear or you could feel
when you hit something or somebody you
see what i'm saying he was saying that
he thought it was a rock or something so
he was not convicted of anything it's
two people
he was issued two citations and let go
i was pronounced dead on the scene you
see what i'm saying
so
like
you know
what could you do you know what i'm
saying you could just look forward to
life like i mean look you know
i got my kids with me
what more could you ask for yeah so
elijah's fine
he survived fine oh yeah look at him
yeah he looks pretty as crazy as ever
what more do you want
and you know
he's a good baby what have you learned
from all of this you've been to oh no i
just learned you know what i'm saying
like don't cherish
you know your house your car your job
you know what i'm saying the material
stuff you know and don't be because you
got money like all the time i had money
you see what i'm saying i was never
without any money in my pocket and i was
maybe like it happened because i always
thought i was better than everybody you
see what i'm saying
but god takes you down a notch you see
what i'm saying and he lets you know
just because you got money
and precious things in your house
that doesn't mean anything the life is
number one you see what i'm saying
the kids are the number one as well you
know so
i think that's
what he made me realize you know that
money and cars and this and that is not
everything it's your family you know
what i'm saying your life you know
so i got a second chance you know what
i'm saying he could give anybody a
second chance
are you in the snow
yeah yeah
all right marissa and family thank you
so much for sharing your story yes and
[Music]
i wish you the best of luck maybe
maybe the viewers might want to donate
to the gofundme that might help yes you
guys are a little bit yes you can do
that by uh the link that's in the video
and uh
in the description and uh
and specify that you wanted to go to
marissa and her family and you could do
that yes
yes
all right you guys we really appreciate
everybody's time that you take to watch
the video and we appreciate everything
that you guys do out there and god bless
everybody and have a blessed day all
right you guys thank you very much
you